in 2013 it's not 2006 anymore you know
but what do you think the biggest
problem filmmakers face today is what is
that I think the biggest challenge from
makerspace today in you know and maybe
it's a challenge they've always pays but
we just never had to confront it head-on
and it's this thing called audience
engagement and we talk about it and I
mentioned this before but it's like when
you talk about audience engagement it's
one of those buzz phrases that nobody
really knows what the heck it means I
mean you kind of do like what is
audience engagement like I guess I need
audience engagement but what it is is
you have to remember your audience's
consists of like let's say you have 10
people in your audience those are 10
living breathing human beings with all
sorts of different obligations in their
life bills to pay families to feed and
when you start thinking about it that
way now personalizes your audience it's
not just a number it's like these are
people and how do I show those people
value how do I give them something in
their life that's memorable and
meaningful so that maybe just for a
glimmer there outside of their
day-to-day maybe just a little bit of
their day is it's been kind of
reflecting on something that I showed
them something that I created is a
filmmaker and that to me is is the
beginning of audience engagement I was
just thinking about them as in devoted
individuals and then figuring out how to
make their day better who can you think
of that's great at engaging their
audience whether it's a Trent Reznor
whether it's a John Lennon years ago who
is somebody that really knows how to be
one-on-one with them even if they're
from a podium speaking yeah well i think
you know coming to light and staying in
the context of filmmaking if you watch
zach braff and we know all know he's a
superstar and all of that but after his
kickstarter campaign I mean he's just
phenomenal engaging the audience he was
somebody that took behind-the-scenes
footage and decisions that were being
made for his movie and made them
interesting and he really wanted to tune
in just to see what he was going to do
next so it was almost as though you
started looking at his project and other
projects like that with people like the
polish brothers and
I'm trying to think up some other
filmmakers but these are people that are
taking the narrative of saying I'm
making a movie and at that point you
perk up and you say that's interesting I
want to see what you're doing I can't
wait for this movie what do you what can
I like how can I get closer to this
thing every day and be a little bit
engaged be a little bit distracted be a
little bit entertained and I think
that's really cool and because of that
one of these people come up with
something and I find it to be engaging
and what do i do I'm prompted to share
with all of my friends and post it on
Facebook and in some cases email it to
people and that's pretty cool
you